I think the automobile is not purely a
functional object it's about the romance
of movement it's about dreaming or
showing qat inspiration which represents
our upper premium proposition my name is
Alfonso Eduardo Alva and executive
design director for infinity
[Music]
so when we were designing the interior
of course the portal doors opened wise
and but we want infinity is a driver's
car company so the driver area the
wonderful leather wraps around the
driver you feel connected to the road
proportion and gesture for me is the
thing I really wanted to capture so what
we did is we created of course a five
meter long car but we also slid the
cabin back of course the glass keep
coming back smoothly it comes to a point
and all the movements of shape come back
and then they celebrate our wonderful
company
[Music]
this texture right here is this fluting
it actually opens and closes so when a
car comes into the city and the engine
needs to breathe the fluting opens when
we're designing a car we're not going
checking boxes and say okay our
competitors are doing this we do that we
find the customer that's frustrated
wants something special and we go for it
so we want to be known as a company that
makes these objects of rarity